I'm Charlie Rose with Gayle King and
Norah O'Donnell minutes ago Isis claimed
responsibility for a deadly terror
attack in Manchester England we're also
learning new details about the bomber
cell phone video show that terrifying
scene inside Manchester Arena thousands
of people rushed to safety after the
explosion just says the ariana grande
concert ended as his bomb set off near
the arena box-office killed at least 22
people most of them children
they included Georgina Calendar a
student in ariana grande fans 59 others
were wounded British prime minister
Theresa May gave her reaction earlier
this morning as so often while we
experienced the worst of humanity in
Manchester last night we also saw the
best the cowardice of the attacker met
the bravery of the emergency services
and the people of Manchester the attempt
to divide us met countless acts of
kindness that brought people closer
together and in the days ahead
those must be the things we remember
this bombing is the deadliest terror
attack in Britain since the London
transit bombings in 2005 witnesses to
last night's attack described the
terrifying scene
I just won formalised we started running
we run straight out the doors all the
way done for the hotel and all I could
hear was screaming people crying
everyone was just running everywhere it
was completely magnets he was a massive
loud bang and I just looked up to where
I heard a coming from and people were
screaming
literally drum
I'm pushing down the stairs to go
outside and people are falling down
girls are crying and we saw these women
being treated by paramedics they had
like open wounds on the legs nor shoes
it was just chaos everything kind of
went calm for about five or six seconds
I mean everyone it was just it was scary
scary and then all of a sudden that was
it there was pandemonium everywhere
police say they arrested one suspect
this morning Mark Phillips is in
Manchester with the latest on the
investigation mark good morning
good morning well in fact the
investigation has been moving forward
even more for a frenetic pace and CBS
News can now confirm the name of the
bomber at least the name that
authorities suspect of the bomber he is
Sulman Abedi a 23 year old man who
security authorities say was known to
them this of course is in addition to
the admission by Isis of responsibility
for this attack it also comes on a day
when Manchester police and this massive
counter-terror operation that's been
carried on here and elsewhere in the UK
have also erect arresting another 23
year old a man they say is from
Manchester itself the attack here last
night the police say was carried out by
one man the issue is how much if any of
the network was behind him or who might
have known of it beforehand the attack
happened in this building behind me the
largest indoor arena in Northern Europe
just as the concert goers were leaving
the attacker was not in the concert but
approached the concert goers and
detonated as they were leaving the death
toll as you say stands at this point at
29 with 59 people still injured many of
them children and many of them with
life-threatening injuries
as well Nora difficult morning there
indeed Mark Phillips in Manchester thank
you